SAYING YOU KNOW YOU YOU DON'T
EVER WORRY ABOUT THE BACK-UP
GETTING INTO A GAME.
BUT THIS MIGHT BE ONE WHERE
ALEX KERFOOT BEHIND THE NET.
LOGAN SHAW.
THAT'S DOWN AND IN
FRONT.
SIMMONDS HAS INSIDE POSITION.
THIS IS IS WHAT KYLE DUBAS CHA
FORECHECKING.
BUT OTTAWA M
OTTAWA INTO THE LEAF ZONE.
FIRST SHOT OF THE Y
UNDERNEATH THE ARM OF FORSBERG
THERE.
HE'S A LITTLE LATE TO NOW A TO.
BEEN THE MOST
DANGEROUS FOR THE SENATORS IN
THIS GAME.
GOOD CHANCERICHIE.
WITH  SEE AUSTON
MATTHEWS ON MONDAY AGAINST THE
NEW YORK RSIDESTEPPING SANDINF.
SAW EARLY.
T.
STUTZLE!
GREAT PASS!
OH, DID YOUOUU KNOW THAT TAVAR
LEFT-HANDER GOES TO THE
BACKHAND.
AND DOWN.
HERE'S TAVARES.
THREE.
HERE'S KNEELANDER AGAIN!
HERE'S STUTZLE.
PASS, BRODIE,   THERE.
NOW TAKES THE OPPORTUNITY.
WATCH THIS MOVE THROUGH THE
NOW LILJEGREN LOST IT AND GETS.
WELL HE SLIDEST GOES IN!
AND IT IS A GOAL FORBATHERSON
HE IS IN AN AWKWARD POSITIONON
>> Referee: AFTEIME THIS YEARE
LEAFS WILL HAVE A HOME AND HOME
RIPPLING PASSED.
HE'S GOT IT
METE.
DEEP AGAIN FOR ENNIS.
CAMPBELL POKED IT RIGHT ONTO L.
PRESSURE FROM THE SENATORS.
AND
BUNTING SCORES!
THE
GLOVE OF BUNTING.
TURNED OVER.
TO BATHEHE
BATHERSON TRYING TO DRAW UP THE
DEFENDER.
RIELLY TO THE OUTSIDE.
MAKES A
TAVARES ON THE OTHER